لا تكتمل فرحه اعياد راس السنه والميلاد
الا بوجودها يختار وائل كسندر بعنايه
فائقه شجره الميلاد ضمن تحضيرات للاحتفال
في جو عائلي
غرار كثير من الروسان الحرب في اوكرانيا
وتداعيتها لا يجب ان تفسد اجواء البهجه
والفرح الذي يسود طيله ايام العيد الميلاد
قبل اشهر اندعى نحو ثلاثين من حكام
المقاطعه في روسيا الى الغاء الاحتفالات
بسبب العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا
وتبيعتها بما فيها تعبئه الجزئيه
دعوات انضم اليها عدد من نواب مجلس الدومه
والسياسيين والمشاهير من مجالات مختلفه
قبل ان تتدخل اداره الرئاسه وتصيب الابقاء
على الاحتفالات مع ادخال تعديلات عليها
والغاء الحفل السنوي الذي يقام في قصر
الكريملين
القوه الغربيه
الاحتفال وانا اؤيد ذلك
تعالى الاصوات بضروره تحويلها هذه الاموال
لدعم القوه الروسيه في وقت تتزايد فيه
الفعاليات المدنيه لجمع التبرعات
للعسكريين على الجبهات
تنفق على سبيل المثال سلطات العاصمه موسكو
سنويا على تزيين الشوارع وساحات واقامه
الفعاليات باعياد راس السنه من 14 الى 25
مليون دولار
ووسط هذا الجدل شدد 70% من المواطن من
الروس بحسب دراسه اجرها المركز الروسي
لدراسه الراي العام على ضروره لابقاء على
الفعاليات الاحتفاليه مع تقليل النفقات في
خدمه
النفقات الحكوميه بسبب العمليه العسكريه
في اوكرانيا فترى قرار اقامه الاحتفالات
رغم ادخال تعديلات عليها الجدل لدى شريحه
من الروس ترى ان الخطوه تتعارض مع اجراءات
البلاد لمواجهه تكاليف الحرب
وتداعيتها الاقتصاديه